con su último discurso provocó que
cientos de miles de personas corrieran a
vacunarse en su alocución en julio
emmanuel mccall anunció el pase
sanitario para acceder a varios lugares
cerrados ahora cuatro meses después se
espera que el noveno discurso del
presidente francés a la ciudadanía desde
el inicio de la pandemia del coronavirus
trata el tema de las vacunas de refuerzo
este se da en el marco del aumento de
los contagios por kobe 19 en francia
como en toda europa el lunes las
mascarillas en las escuelas volvieron a
ser obligatorias en 39 departamentos y
sólo la mitad de los elegibles se han
puesto las vacunas de refuerzo es decir
sólo 4 de 7.7 millones una obligación
que sigue dividiendo a la población no
tenemos total libertad de elección a
pase prefiero eso que volver al entierro
el mes pasado la prórroga del base
sanitario hasta el próximo verano ya
provocó un fuerte debate en el senado y
el jefe de la asamblea nacional afirmó
que es poco probable que se revoque el
pase para quienes no tengan la dosis de
refuerzo a sus en este momento la opción
no está sobre la mesa a sólo cinco meses
de la primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales se trata de un discurso
muy esperado
sin hacer campaña oficialmente se prevé
que majo destaque los éxitos de su
administración pero también que hable
sobre su visión económica del país y de
las conversaciones sobre el clima que
están en curso al mismo tiempo que
esbozó sus planes para el desempleo y
las reformas pensionales